[Music]
I'm thrilled to say that Mary's not just
someone I admire and respect in the
industry but she's a great friend and
it's my honor to present this Daytime
Emmy Lifetime Achievement Award to the
incomparable Mary Hart longtime former
Entertainment Tonight host Mary Hart
accepted the Lifetime Achievement Award
at Sunday's Daytime Emmy Awards Wow does
it feel great to be here I am excited to
speak to you tonight because what an
honor
really I mean you are true trailblazer
for what we do and I'm hearing tonight
that you weren't even thinking this is
the job for you huh I mean how surreal
is this moment it it is surreal and
especially looking back because it took
me a while and we were in such a frenzy
and in those early days literally there
was nobody who thought this show could
last so we were doing the show I was on
the road and selling it and saying it is
not fluff as I said I would have said
Vickers but um it it was it turned out
to be and it didn't take me all that
long to realize it that I loved the
people I worked with I loved what we
were doing and we were creating a brand
new genre of TV I cannot tell you how
much I have loved being a part of
Entertainment Tonight how blessed I feel
to have been right in the middle of the
Hollywood community and I am probably
the luckiest person on the planet how
did you keep your emotions in check
because you were really poised at all
your Mary Hart of course but I wasn't I
mean my heart was beating and I had to
use notes which is not my modus operandi
normally but and thinking about my mom
honestly so I knew I was keeping that
emotion bottled up and I knew that I
wanted to convey what my mom was all
about and it truly was
about tolerance and really trying to
understand the other side the other
point of view whatever side you're on
you